[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 21 février
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de cette édition professionnels
du bâtiment et associations lancent
l'alertent la construction de logements
neufs a nettement reculé en 2018 en
france un paradoxe avec une demande
d'habitat toujours importante quel
constat dans le département et quelles
solutions
pierre cojan président de la ffb des
yvelines est notre invité vous avez déjà
sûrement vu cette mention sous les
panneaux d'entrée des communes le label
villes et villages fleuris à 60 ans il
distingue les collectivités qui
promeuvent le fleurissement et la
présence des espaces verts cette semaine
à plaisir les prix du concours pour
l'année 2018 ont été remis et le
deuxième focus patrimoine du mois
direction conflans sainte honorine pour
découvrir le château fnr longtemps à
l'abandon ce site de la fin du 19e
siècle a été réhabilité désormais lieu
d'imagination et de création numérique
il a est déjà accueilli plus de 200
artistes et puis autre invité dans ce
journal nous prendrons connaissance du
programme lancé en cette veille à des
vacances à divers le programme du centre
alfred de vigny à voisins le bretonneux
c'est à à la fin de ce journal
à deux jours de l'ouverture du salon de
l'agriculture le début du procès de
l'abattoir de houdan le directeur trois
salariés du site et un agent est des
services vétérinaires comparaissent
devant le tribunal de grande instance à
versailles est jugée suite à une plainte
de l214 une vidéo révélée par
l'association de défense animale en 2017
à montre des cas de maltraitance sur des
cochons
l214 espère avec ce procès le début
d'une prise de conscience sur la
non-conformité de plusieurs chaînes
d'abattage en france les propos
recueillis au micro de patrick jacq de
dick cheney
et on comptera mention est en moi c'est
peut-être quand même un pas vers la fin
des abattoirs comme étant des zones de
non droit et donc c'est important
ce procès se tienne la faire on a failli
classé sans suite elle a été jugée digne
de passer devant un juge
donc on attend dans la détermination des
responsabilités des uns et des autres
contre le directeur de l'abattoir agents
des services vétérinaires et les trois
affaires il tire la sonnette d'alarmé
professionnels du bâtiment associations
d'élus et caritatif s'inquiètent de la
baisse des constructions de logements
neufs en france en 2018 à moins 7,6 pour
cent de permis de construire accordés en
moins - 7 % par dont deux mises en
construction des données est paradoxal
quand on sait elle les besoins accrus en
logement et ce chiffre 4 millions de
personnes qui sont mal logés en france
bonsoir pierre cojan bonsoir vous êtes
le président de la fédération française
du bâtiment des yvelines lors ce cri d'
alerte a été fait notamment part votre
fédération au niveau national et ce que
la situation est préoccupante aussi dans
les yvelines
ah oui alors se préoccupe on n'a plus
l'âge d'avoir un peu plus de d'activité
mais on ressent déjà on a eu déjà avant
le ralentissement en 2010 8,2
puis-je on est à pissos 2003 nous sommes
en 2019 à -0 5 logements neufs plus 2008
il a - 4 5 et on ressent avec les permis
construire qui ont beaucoup diminué tout
de suite dont et sur le deuxième
semestre 2010 9
on va ressentir la bestia que les faits
aient encore peut-être pas aussi fort
dans les yvelines mais il va se
ressentir sur l'année 2019 il va se
ressentir
il va s'en sortir normalement on
commence déjà à le ressentir donc sur
les grosses structures qui les payent
construire ont bâti après il n'y a pas
de permis qui sortent donc travail et
quel est l'état d'esprit des
professionnels du bâtiment dans les
yvelines et ce qu'ils vous ont fait part
de leurs inquiétudes
oui parce que l'on fait des réunions là
on a une donneuse grand débat qui a
démarré donc on a voulu participer nous
avons déjà fait deux réunions donc on
veut y participer on veut que ça ça ça
s'améliore parce que on en est depuis en
plus tôt trois mois dans 20 dans la
tente on sait pas ce qui va se passer et
on a aussi le lait les les
les gens sont assez frileuses il ya là
la fiscalité n'est pas pérenne donc les
les laonnoises pas mal dans le bal
priver les gens ils hésitent à investir
ce n'est pas catastrophique mais on y
arrive gentiment et le président
national a eu raison de l'alerté et moi
je confirme
alors comment on peut l'expliquer
justement cette chute de la construction
des logements neufs est ce qu'il n'ya
pas une première explication à chercher
vous parliez de la fiscalité dans la
baisse des aides publiques
pierre cojan ce chiffre juste avant de
vous donner la parole avec le prêt à
taux zéro on peut se faire financer
jusqu'à 20% de la construction de son
logement avant c'était 40 % c'est à dire
qu'il ya une grosse baisse par ce prêt
sur ce prêt à taux zéro plus ça dépend
des régions il ya eu il ya des zones qui
ont été définis donc c'est donc c'est
pas évident il faut il faut inciter les
gens à construire et ne nous en plus
chez nous dans les yvelines dans la
région parisienne ile de france on a le
coût du foncier qui est cher donc ce
n'est pas évident mais c'est vrai que
les gens blog et l'état a aussi
fonctionné les aider les constructeurs
sociaux
donc ils ont tout ponctionner est là
pour l'instant on devait attendre ce qui
donne bonne et du travail pour nos
demandes sociales
ils ont bloqué et le privé les gens sont
frileux ont pas envie savent pas rien et
surtout c'est la fiscalité
il faut qu'il fait quelque chose de
profitable à la construction et que ça
soit pérenne
si tu pouvais ce que ça soulève pas là
la question peut-être de trop dépendance
du secteur du bâtiment sur ce vis-à-vis
des des aides publiques des financements
publics
oui oui bah le batîment le bâtiment il
est dépendant
les aides publiques il en faut mais
c'est pas tout et tu vas t'il bien
répartis et les gens ne savent pas quand
on construit on investit sur des longues
années et je pense qu'il faut donner
envie aux gens de construire
donnant-donnant nous l'envient d'avoir
envie et que les joies que des choix que
l'état nous donne les moyens d'avancer
de deux de construire peut-être l'une
des pistes c'est cette filière de la
rénovation énergétique est ce que vous
en attendez beaucoup est ce que
peut-être il y a encore un une attente
de votre part sur sur cette filière de
la rénovation énergétique bah oui on en
en parle à la maison qu'est-ce qui fait
euh je pense qu'il faudrait inciter
surtout à faire des travaux sur
l'énergétique plutôt que de punir ces
postes soit en incitant leurs ça que
parfois en augmentant les prix des
carburants ou d'une énergie on n'oblige
un petit peu mais c'est ce que je pense
qu'il faut il faut il faut donner de
donner l'envié aux gens d'investir parce
que mélé la commission énergétique
on s'aperçoit que quand on a fait des
travaux c'est rentable la fin du vrai
mais là il recrée actuellement la
chaudière à 1 euro mes fils et sa touche
que peu de personne en personne pour
faire tomber donne rien qu'a donc cessé
d effet d'annoncé mais ses pensées pour
savoir ce qu'on veut c'est quelque chose
qui me booste et pour retrouver ces
solutions ne sont pas reliés de la
participation grand débat national cette
thématique du logement elle a toute sa
place dans tout ça parce qu'on a on a
fait deux grands débats on en a fait
avec les élus on a un fan autres à notre
fédération on se devait d'en bas comme
tout le monde doit participer
on voudrait pas que ça ça on va envoyer
devant avait avec l'équipe qui va gagner
parce que pour l'instant c'est tout est
bloqué c'est vrai que il ya eu un
blocage au niveau national niveau de
l'état et là avec les ce qui se passe on
pense à savoir depuis trois ans et trois
mois
genre il n'y a pas d'argent donc il faut
trouver un système mais on est tous
prêts à débattre et les débuts de grands
débats
il prend sa forme et nous et nous sommes
nous les en têtes de liste pour donner
dire de leurs revendications
peut-être plus fier de lisibilité sur
les différentes aides qui existent ça
tient pas aujourd'hui une multiplicité
des valaisannes et qui chevauchait
dirige art et on crée on préférait avoir
aucune aide
mais que nous laisse travailler qu'on
diminue les chats les charges sociales
qui sont les gens sachent après de trop
et on freine l'embauché
on a tous envie d'embaucher mais on a
créé il ya un début d'un beau jeu faire
n'a pas travaillé tellement embaucher on
était à plus à plus de 6 la dernière on
a pu 04 les gens qu'embaucher dix mois
on va débaucher on n'a même pas
rentabilisé dès leur embauche on a fait
un dernier mot peut-être sur la loi et
avant ça apportait une simplification
justement cette loi est lent oui oui oui
oui c'est bien mais est-ce que la beauty
raes qui va être appliqué aux boues
seront aux anges quelque chose on est
trop dans le flou encore sur sur seine
qui avait besoin d'un bâtiment en plus
tous les trois on voudrait que ce soit
solide et bien ce sera le mot de la fin
merci pierre cojan président de la
fédération française du bâtiment des
yvelines et on peut retrouver bien sûr
toute l'actualité de votre fédération
sur son site internet elle déplacement
ministériel ce matin dans les yvelines
jean michel blanquer un ministre de
l'éducation nationale et son homologue à
la transition écologique et solidaire
françois de rugy était à conflans sainte
honorine au collège d autres l ont ils
sont venus lancer cube un concours
d'économie d'énergie entre
établissements scolaires l'objectif
notamment mobiliser les élèves sur la
question et sensibiliser au bon usage
pour optimiser la consommation
le grand débat dont on parlait il ya un
instant à animer les habitants de
guyancourt et de montigny
bretonneux les deux communes ont
organisé une réunion commune ça se
passait à l'université versailles saint
quentin ce mercredi les participants ont
pu parfois faire quelques propositions
contradictoires les précisions avec ce
sujet de nicolas d'andré un amphithéâtre
universitaire lieu du savoir pour
débattre de l'avenir du pays
voilà le cadre du grand débat national
commun à montigny le bretonneux et
guyancourt
environ 300 participants avec notamment
des propositions différentes autour des
finances et des services publics sur la
dépense publique qu'il faut la réduire
parce que aujourd'hui elle c'est l'aide
à peu près 50 7% du pib s est
anormalement élevé déjà déjà le point
lundi son rapport est une bonne chose
les fonctionnaires travaillent dans des
conditions effectivement sur le terrain
c'est ça devient très très compliqué
mais par ailleurs dans leur vie
personnelle aussi ça bien extrêmement
compliqué les quatre thématiques ont
animé le débat avec la participation de
quelques jeunes impliqués notamment sur
les questions de transition écologique
je suis là parce que je pense que c'est
intéressant de s'intéresser à
l'actualité politique et on peut pas se
plaindre d'un côté ne pas être entendus
par par les élites et et ne pas venir là
donc je viens pour ça on fait partie
d'une communauté de la cité on a besoin
d'un voilà de montrer qu'on est là les
jeunes bon c'est vrai que c'est on est
censé être beaucoup d'étudiants ce soir
on voit beaucoup de
personnes entre guillemets mais voilà
pour faciliter l'organisation de cet
événement les villes de montigny le
bretonneux et guyancourt honte oeuvrer
en commun lu vs qu a demandé à alexis
constantin professeur de droit
d'orchestrer les échanges c'est d'animer
ce débat d'essayer de faire émerger les
arguments de chacun les idées les
questions les sentiments mais le tout
avec calme sérénité comme il se doit
dans un débat au sein d'une démocratie
il ya des questions qui ont été posées
il ya des réflexions il ya des
suggestions d'organisation de réductions
de dépenses et tous ont depuis trois
mois il ya quand même énormément de
manifestations qui se sont passé et les
gens avaient besoin de s'exprimer aussi
de pouvoir effectivement dire ce qu'ils
avaient sur le coeur
ce qu'ils souhaitaient comme
modification des propositions aussi
parce que ce soit par exemple ya eu
énormément de propositions
le grand débat national doit se clôturer
le 15 mars prochain une synthèse des
idées doit être réalisée courant avril à
l'éprît villes et villages fleuris ont
été remis cette semaine à plaisir en
2018 63 communes yvelinois se sont vu
décerner de une à quatre fleurs
cette année ce label a une saveur
particulière puisqu'il fête ses 60 ans
le reportage d'aurélie rose depuis 60
ans et petit panneau jaune qui
fleurissent aux entrées de nos communes
sont toujours autant convoité en 2018
dans les yvelines 63 communes ont été
labellisés villes et villages fleuris
chaque année on en a quelques unes
supplémentaire et on voit une
participation plus en plus importante
pour ses 60 printemps le label s'est
refait une petite beauté
mais ces objectifs n'ont pas changé il
garantit les démarches d'amélioration du
cadre de vie et renforce les qualités
d'attractivité des communes donc je joue
plus la quantité de fleurs mais nous
nous avons une grille d'évaluation
transversale qui récompense en fait une
stratégie vertueuse des espaces verts
une volonté politique
le jury composé d'une vingtaine de
membres a parcouru l'été dernier
l'ensemble du département
fontenay-le-fleury par ex
il a obtenu sa troisième fleur dans les
yvelines seules trois villes ont de
nouveau décroché le graal à savoir
quatre fleurs c'est le cas du vésinet
une habitude depuis 1992 tout est
possible aussi avec avec une
participation aussi de l'urbanisme une
participation des élus sans leur
implication et l'implication des
services techniques pour pourraient pas
obtenir ou garder les quatre fleurs qui
sont quand même une valorisation de
qualité de vie un label qui encourage le
renforcement de la nature en ville pour
découvrir les bonnes pratiques déjà
mises en place aux quatre coins du
département des visites sont organisées
tout au long de l'année
c'est destiné aux élus des qui sont en
charge de ce sujet développement durable
nature en ville et ses destinée aussi
aux jardiniers des espaces verts des
communes yvelinoise les inscriptions
pour le label 2019 ouvriront en avril
prochain
un mot de santé lundi les bénévoles de
la croix rouge de saint quentin en
yvelines organisé une journée portes
ouvertes à maurepas depuis quatre ans
tous les samedis après midi la maison de
voisinage des coudrais accueille une
halte répit détente alzheimer un espace
de convivialité où sont accueillis
pendant quelques heures des personnes
atteintes de la maladie ce lieu qui
permet de soulager les aidants sera
prochainement ouvert également les
lundis après midi les propos sont
collectées par aurélien on s'était
aperçu que pour les malades
c'était une resocialisation qui
il aurait été bénéfique en plus du fait
que ça libère les dents en quelques
heures nous nous nous occupons en
fonction de leurs oeufs dans affinités
et au de ce qui intéresse peut déjà
[Musique]
société que hal au golf
et quand il fait très beau comme
aujourd'hui éventuellement aux
promenades du théâtre pour sortir de
l'isolément et reprendre confiance en
soi depuis huit ans guyancourt propose
deux semaines de stage à des personnes
au chômage une collaboration entre le
service emploi de la ville et la ferme
de bel ébat marylène iapichino a suivi
ces comédiens d'un jour
donc toi tu dit olivier alors tu prends
ta femme tu prends l'ascenseur ce mardi
matin à guyancourt on se distribuent les
répliques et faut que amos et une sève à
sa disposition
ça va être toi ouais et les roulent tous
sont en recherche d'emploi ils
participent à ce stage pour une reprise
de confiance en soi
en fait moi je suis justement comédien
actuellement j'ai fait j'étais un petit
peu
un peu sortis du circuit donc je vais
voir les services sociaux du coût de
leurs yeux sont allumés quand j'ai dit
bon comédien m'en voyez ici
le but c'est pas qu'on soit des
professionnels c'est vraiment on prend
tant qu'amateur et en tant que personnes
qui vont juste s'amuser juste montrer un
peu ce qu'est ce qu'elles peuvent valoir
deux semaines de préparation durant
lesquelles ils ont écrit leurs propres
textes et monter une pièce de 15 minutes
le thème était tout trouvé le travail
alors prenez d'abord et maintenant au
ils sont dirigés par le metteur en scène
françois chaffin en résidence à la ferme
de bel ébat ses douze stagiaires
monteront sur scène en avant première de
sa pièce
c'est une manière aussi de dédramatiser
de prendre un peu de distance par
rapport à un quotidien assez solitaire
de recherche d'emploi le grand jour est
arrivé dernier moment de stress en
coulisses moi j'ai peur d'avoir des
trous
j'ai peur de pas savoir comment m'y
prendre j'ai peur que les gens plus âgés
par quoi avant des pâtes et des
spectateurs sous les projecteurs moi ce
stage issue d'un partenariat entre la
ville et la ferme de bel ébat existe
depuis 2012 une aventure que les élus en
charge de l'emploi et de la culture ne
sont pas prêtes à abandonner garantir le
la prise en compte pour les demandeurs
d'emploi de même aussi bien dans leur
corps que dans leur expression c'est
très important
les artistes qui sont en résidence ici
on cette mission aussi d'aller chercher
les publics
un vrai groupe qui s'est formé désormais
prêt à affronter cette recherche
d'emploi bien entouré et vous confiance
l'information était presque acté depuis
quelques mois elle a été officialisée
hier coignières sort du projet de
piscine intercommunale avec les villes
voisines d'elancourt et de maurepas une
décision est prise hier mercredi lors du
conseil municipal de coignières la
commune lourd a tout de même des lignes
d'eau pour ces écoliers cette piscine
doit ouvrir à l'été 2010 9 sur le
territoire de maurepas et du haras la
création numérique le château vanderbilt
connaît une nouvelle vie à conflans
sainte honorine longtemps abandonné le
site a été réhabilité par l'association
usine éphémère en lieux d'imagination
artistique depuis plus de deux cents
artistes ont été accueillis par la
structure est découverte de ce château
éphémère avec mélanie poker le château
van der bilt est à carrières sous poissy
depuis 1885 2000 mètres carrés de
bâtiments williams qui sam van der bilt
un homme d'affaires et éleveur de
chevaux américains achètent la propriété
en 1906 pour sa proximité un manoir
légèrement surélevé pour voir
l'hippodrome aujourd'hui disparu il a
bâti j'irai son empire équestre ici et
fait donc de l'élevage de chevaux
sa spécialité pendant un peu plus d'une
quinzaine d'années voilà donc des riches
propriétaires se sont succédé et à la
sortie de la 2ème guerre mondiale il eu
un premier abandon de ce lieu puis donc
les sablières moderne en fait ici et
exploite donc le sable et granulats on
ont fait leur siège social voilà ils ont
aussi exploiter les terres attenantes au
château le site connaît un nouvel
abandon dans les années 90 squatter puis
rachetée par la collectivité le site a
connu une réhabilitation par les usines
éphémère qui récupère des lieux en
déshérence depuis 1987
dans cette pièce
préserver de quoi de boiseries sont
d'origine avec quelques graffitis bon
voilà c'était retravailler au pin pon c
etc
et il ya eu en fait c'était assez
rapides et mieux un an et demi de
travaux donc c'est vraiment rapide et un
million deux je crois de budget pour
2010 m car et c'est sera lancée au prix
du mètre carré c'est pas énorme
le château van der wiel devient le
château éphémère géré par van der lab
fabrique sonore et numérique en novembre
2014 un lieu de création artistique avec
trois studios de répétition et un
d'enregistrement met à disposition un
atelier de travail
on met à disposition des outils donc ça
peut être des systèmes de sonorisation
des lumières des vidéoprojecteurs
évidemment le soutien donc humain
puisque voilà il ya une équipe au
château on est six personnes et de cette
équipe
ben voilà on connecte l'artiste soit la
vie la cité soit évidemment à d'autres
acteurs culturels donc d'autres lieux
des endroits d'exposition de monstration
voilà tout un réseau professionnel qu'on
peut aussi à mettre en connexion avec un
artiste résident lieu de la bid oui de
la réflexion le fab lab voit naître de
nombreuses créations établi machines à
coudre et imprimantes 3d permettent de
faire naître les inspirations
artistiques
on fabrique des objets donc on peut
réaliser ses rêves de manière voilà donc
on va prototype et certains objets on
rend accessible du coût des machines
outils ou des outils numériques au grand
public
voilà on est dans une démarche de
vulgarisation
cette culture scientifique et de toutes
ces démarches artistes en herbe ou
public amateur le château éphémère
propose aussi des ateliers de 9 mars
prochain les familles pourront créer des
têtes d'animaux en volume avant de
refermer ce journal les plus jeunes
seront ravis demain débutent les
vacances d'hiver deux semaines de congé
pour se reposer mais aussi pour faire
des activités le centre alfred de vigny
à voisins le bretonneux propose plein
d'animations pendant ses vacances pour
en parler aurélie arnaud bonsoir ça vous
est la coordinatrice de ce lieu alors
c'est une période toujours animé pour le
centre alfred de vigny cette période des
vacances oui bien sûr toutes les
vacances scolaires on prépare et met en
place des stages culturels et
artistiques toujours plaints plusieurs
activités qui sont proposées à faire
d'ailleurs le point sur l'essentiel des
activités pendant ces vacances d'hiver
alors notamment seront proposées pour
par ce centre alfred de vigny des cours
de poterie la première semaine et de
dessin à la deuxième et ça c'est en lien
avec un projet que vous avez développé
avec la commune de voisins-le-bretonneux
tout à fait vrai puisque toutes les
créations que les jeunes sortiront de
ces ateliers là pendant sept ans dans
ces stages seront exposés à de coville
lors du salon imagine qui met en avant à
la créativité des des moins de 18 ans
mais c'est des stages animés par des
professionnels de la poterie du dessin
des artistes qui font des stages déjà
l'année au centre alfred de vigny ça
donc ce cours de poterie et de dessins
qui sont malheureusement déjà complet
mais on va on va proposer d'autres
activités tout de suite alors à partir
du lundi 25 février jusqu'au mercredi 27
février
il ya un atelier d'aiguilhe qu'est ce
que ce qu'est ce qu'on va faire
concrètement pendant cet atelier c'est
un atelier qui réunit plusieurs
générations donc c'est un mail des
adolescentes qui déjà du niveau qui
décide d'apprendre à travailler la
couture avec des personnes plus plume
qui maîtrisent un peu plus le sujet donc
c'est l'apprentissage de la machine à
coudre plus le choix des tissus
différents prendre de croche et c'est
donc l'idée de favoriser les liens entre
les plus jeunes et les plus âgés sur ce
genre d'activités il ya un spectacle
également à voir en famille ça sera
toujours dans la première semaine le
jeudi 28 février
coriolis et et détritus un spectacle qui
aborde le thème de la pollution marine
c'est ça c'est plus les gels plus
globalement le développement durable
donc c'est un spectacle de la compagnie
compass australine compagnie parisienne
donc c'est un théâtre familial qui est
adapté pour tous les âges pour qui est
vraiment une prise de conscience ludique
sur sur la son développement durable
donc ça c'est le jeudi 28 février ce
spectacle coriolis et détritus à 17h il
faut bien préciser l'horaire mais vous
tout à fond on peut retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site internet chez
alfred point info alors ça fait moins
rêver mais les vacances c'est aussi fait
pour réviser n'oublions pas que les
troisièmes ont le brevet à la fin de
l'année et les premières et terminales
le baccalauréat lors le centre alfred de
vigny proposera des stages
eureka cd des stages de soutien scolaire
pendant ces vacances tout à fait donc il
reste des places disponibles pour les
semaines la deuxième semaine des
vacances donc du 4 au 8 mars
on a des cours d'anglais et de physique
de français de mathématiques pour tous
les niveaux pour terminal collège
seconde première avec des professeurs
qui sont diplômés qui qui travaillent
déjà dans les collèges et dans les
lycées de la région
donc qui ont qui connaissent le
programme et qui sont là pour s'adapter
aux besoins des élèves pour les remettre
à niveau et les encourager pour leur
diplôme
du coup pour à potasser tous ces cours
vous l'avez dit c'est ouvert aux
collégiens et aux lycéens c'est avec ces
stages tout à fait et pour terminer cet
entretien on a présenté l'essentiel en
quelques mois qu'y aura-t-il d'autres au
centre alfred de vigny pendant ses
vacances
elle aurait il y aura aussi des stages
d'informatique scratch et steam ou de
stages bien distincts l'un pour
apprendre les bases de la programmation
informatique pour programmer un robot et
l'autre pour animer pour les
les rudiments du dessin animé pour
animer des personnages donc ça aussi au
centre avec quelqu'un qui est passionné
par la programmation informatique pour
les plus jeunes une question pratique
pour participer à tous ces ateliers il
faut s'inscrire
je mérite tout à fait ma vous pouvez
vous pré inscrire via le site internet
et puis là le centre est ouvert du lundi
au samedi de 9h à 12h et de 14h à 18h
pour finaliser ces inscriptions donc
l'inscription pré inscription sur
internet on retrouve bien sûr l'ensemble
du programme pour ces vacances de
février
sur ce site à chier alfred point info
merci aurélie arnaud d'être se masser
sur ce plateau coordinatrice du centre
alfred de vigny à voisins le bretonneux
voilà c'est la fin du set 8 journal
rester avec nous dans un instant le 7-8
loisirs de marina iapichino pour
connaître est davantage d'idées de
sorties et d'activités à faire dans le
coin belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]